donald trump did a wild coronavirus
press briefing yesterday
and instead of covering it all in one
story i'm sort of going to chop it up
because there's actually
so much insanity that happened at
yesterday's press briefing
that i don't want to just lump it all
together in one segment so we're going
to start with one of the strangest
moments
donald trump confirmed that he's really
jealous of dr anthony fauci
and he doesn't like the fact that people
like dr
fauci but don't like trump what's
fascinating about this
is we speculated months ago that the
reason dr
fauci started being pushed to the
sidelines by donald trump
was that trump didn't like the attention
that fauci was getting that trump was
jealous this was our speculation based
on what we know about donald trump
uh dr fauci was well liked dr fauci was
seen as authoritative on the virus dr
fauci was seen as trustworthy trump was
not and thus we started seeing less and
less of dr
fauci check out this insane clip
where trump just says the thing that we
all
suspected take a look anybody in the
world i have a graph that i'd love to
show you i'm
perhaps you've seen it where we're up
here and the rest of the world is down
at a level
that's just a tiny fraction of what
we've done in terms of testing
so it sort of is curious a man works for
us with us very closely dr fauci and dr
burks also highly
thought of and yet they're highly
thought of but nobody likes me
it can only be my personality that's all
go ahead that's a president
that's a 73 year old adult a wealthy
adult arguably
in the most powerful position of anybody
on planet earth who is motivated by
sort of playground elementary school
level nonsense why do people like fauci
but they don't like me i'm the one who
has fouchy working
for me well fouchy's a doctor and he's
trying to save
lives while trump is just sort of not a
particularly bright guy whose priority
is getting himself
re-elected and this 35-second clip just
explains so much this is a trump mask
off
moment he's showing us he's dead jealous
of dr anthony fauci earlier this week we
learned i mean it's all coming together
now earlier this week we learned that
when donald trump canceled his plan to
throw out a first pitch at yankee
stadium on august 15th
there was really no such plan in other
words nothing had been scheduled
trump ended up canceling it but there
was nothing scheduled
and we learned that trump only announced
this
because he was jealous that dr fauci
was throwing out the first pitch and
when we went back and looked at the
timing
trump claimed that he was going to be
throwing out a first pitch at yankee
stadium just an hour
or two before dr fauci actually threw
out a first pitch at yankee stadium
this triggered trump's jealousy so
strongly that he just made it up last
week i'm scheduled to throw out the
first pitch
and now he makes it very clear why is it
you know anthony fauci has such a high
approval
i have a low approval people like him
people don't like me why is that
the complaints of like a little kid he's
just jealous he's extremely jealous and
i don't know about
you but i don't want a president
motivated by jealousy
and it comes out so strongly here and
when we look back
it's so illuminating because we we have
this movement in the united states that
for years
under donald trump and even before it
goes back to john kerry
actually in in fact the feminization
of intelligent and well-spoken men in
american society
the claiming you know this alpha male
versus
beta male stuff this
has gone back a long time and if you
remember
the 2004 presidential election as many
in the audience do
george w bush versus john kerry john
kerry
couched as framed as the feminized man
the less than really a man why well
because he
uh went surfing once or windsurfing
wakeboarding something like that
because he spoke french because he was
educated because he was a boston guy
and the truth was it was actually george
w
bush who figured out a way to get out of
the military
like by their own standards which
include the military military service as
a proxy
to manliness and being a real man so to
speak
it was john kerry who went to vietnam
while
george bush flew a plane for a little
bit and ended up bailing pretty quickly
because of his privileged position and
so we that was the first sign to me and
i'm sure it goes back longer than that
but that was the first race where i
really saw this completely backwards you
know they framed the left as feminized
not real men even though the reality is
it's they
who avoid the stereotypically manly
things
like military service and then we saw it
with barack
obama you know law professor obama
who likes music that is less than
totally masculine and all of this other
stuff
and the epitome of it is really donald
trump i mean this alpha male beta male
stuff has exploded during donald trump
and donald trump is the epitome
sorry donald trump is the antithesis
the antithesis of what they claim makes
a manly man trump figuring out ways to
get himself out of military service
because of his bone spurs which many
people don't really take seriously
and now once again is it
masculine to be endlessly insecure
and say why do they like him but not me
is it
masculine to be so
fragile that you're constantly having to
attack
others and it doesn't show strength to
me
and very very uh revealing that donald
trump really exposed
what is underlying a lot of his bizarre
behavior and has been for a long time
now that's part one of this three-part
analysis of yesterday's press briefing
then it got even weirder when trump told
a black reporter that he looks like
michael bloomberg let's look at that
next
one of our sponsors today is a snack
brand called
just the cheese and they are giving our
audience
20 percent off all of their products
just the cheese is a snack bar
made with only one ingredient 100
percent
all natural wisconsin cheese it is
crunchy
it is a baked snack created to mimic the
cheese that bakes off into the pan and
gets crunchy
when you make a grilled cheese sandwich
it's absolutely delicious and because
every bite
is just cheese that's all it is it's
packed with calcium and protein
has virtually no carbs no sugar
completely gluten free
perfect if you're looking for a low carb
snack on the go available in three
varieties
aged cheddar grilled cheese
and jalapeno my favorite a little bit of
a kick
you know i love a kick just the cheese
is manufactured by a family
cheese company in the heart of wisconsin
it's simple
tasty crunchy delicious again it's
called
just the cheese you can find their
amazon page by going to davidpakman.com
cheese and you can get 20 percent off by
using code
20 pacman at checkout that's
davidpakman.com
cheese and use the code 2-0-p-a-k-m-a-n
for 20 off